jacques dutronc d'après ces images on
dirait que gerra pires vous à forger
leur holden othello moderne
mais contrairement à celui de
shakespeare
notre damon qui est jane birkin dans le
film vous là tuez pas vous essayer de la
gagner non seulement j'essaye de la
gagner mais une somme que je la gagne
mais ma faim j'irais jusqu'à dire
posséder si je puis dire mais en effet
votre impression est plus nette que la
mienne car je crois que pour une fois
c'est vous qui venez d'avoir vu le film
cet après midi est renversant les rôles
qu'est ce que ça fait de voir pour la
première fois le film qu'on a tourné il
ya il ya quand même quelques mois oui
non mais je trouvais ça déjà plus
honnête de voir un film ne serait ce que
pour en parler déjà et puis ne serait ce
que par rapport aux autres comédiens
avec qui vous avez joué et c'est ce que
ça fait comme impression c'est une
impression première de d'un montage
excellence parce que c'est lorsque j'ai
tourné ce film là c'était plus un puzzle
qu'autre chose je trouve ça tient très
bien debout et j'ai encore des ris de
grâce au sourire que j'ai eu de
nombreuses fois pendant la projection
est ce que vous apportez vous même dans
le dialogue certains mots certaines
expressions parce que on découvre à
travers tous les finement disons que
disons qu'il ya peut-être c'est
peut-être pas d'amener les choses c'est
peut-être la manière de les dire
peut-être qu'il faut peut-être pensé qu'
elles proviennent plus de moi que du
scénario mais je pense pas avoir
surenchéri nicole de bureau je crois pas
est ce que vous trouvez qu'il y à une
séparation totale entre le personnage du
ton cinéma et le monde de la chanson à
la fois dans ce que vous écrivez comme
parole qu'aux musiques
il ya deux choses différentes bon enfin
il ya déjà le public je pense que le
public est différent lorsque l'on chante
enfin je parle maintenant je ne fais
plus de tourner comme on dit les gens
vous allez chez eux grâce à la
télévision alors que le cinéma va
peinture moment où un film sort
exclusivité les gens se déplacent pour
les hommes c'est peut-être une des
grandes différences et de là à dire que
les personnages sont enfin je resterai
toujours un peu moi je vous dis rien pas
de réseau je vais ça va vous emmener le
projet littéraire car plein de gens le
savent vous avez un projet d'écrivains
aussi vous auriez dû lire seriez dû lire
lire le c'est une revue dirigée
d'ailleurs peint par pivot et vous
auriez repris qu'en fait je n'ai jamais
écrit